hello everyone my name is markiplier and
welcome to the eggnog ice bath challenge
as you can see we have eggnog 20 gallons
of it and we have an ice bath 20 gallons
of it and so we're going to combine
these two elements there's going to be
an incredible chemical reaction out of
it and then we are going to submerge
ourselves in this and discover the
Fountain of Youth and in doing this we
are going to answer your Twitter
questions about Christmas
our Christmas you are Christmas any
Christmas in general we're going to get
to the bottom of the answers here yes
I'm going to say time you said we isn't
interests you on this one yeah probably
maybe and I'm sorry if my voice is a bit
gravelly I'm still sick I thought I was
getting better yesterday and then I
screamed for five hours straight and
suddenly my voice is a little bit deeper
than it usually is but maybe that'll be
good this time so we're going to get
started and we're going to get a lot of
footage of us dumping this eggnog in the
ice bath
[Music]
or wasteful cue the sexy music that was
not sexy at all
that was the least sexy thing I've ever
done in my life okay here we go
everybody ready ah slippery
[Applause]
[Music]
hmm okay do not pour that on me
it is colder than water I will tell you
that it is like a it was like it's like
an ice it's like an ice water salt
mixture cuz you're sowing Saul and I
can't stay in your long okay so what did
you ask Santa for this year
thankfully I'm lucky enough that I don't
really ask for much these days one of
the things that I wanted most is to be
able to spend Christmas with my friends
and family so I'm very happy to be able
to do that oh oh
festively pewds asks will we ever get
that Christmas album and I would really
like to be able to get that Christmas
album too but to be honest getting sick
on the way my voice isn't where it was
and we were planning to do a full cover
of a few Christmas songs bla things got
in the way but expect some cover songs
of things very soon Jackie Xmas said do
you still believe in Santa Claus I don't
because that's not physically possible
but I like the I
yo Santa a big jolly old fellow that
just yells at all his bastard kiddies
the cat cadaver asks what's your
favorite Christmas movie it's Jim
Carrey's How the Grinch Stole Christmas
I watch it every single year
this is uncomfortably close Tyler just
get a goddamn shot from over there and
stop moving around like a goof sugarplum
Shaylee asks when how did you find out
that Santa wasn't real um when I could
first think anybody that believes in
service actually I'm pretty sure my dad
never told us that Santa was actually
real pretty much I just think he wanted
all the credit for all the presents
anyway Oh Gabrielle names asked what are
some family traditions your family
usually does we have this game called
hide the pickle and that may sound
sexual but it's not we would hide a
small pickle in the Christmas tree and
if you found the pickle before anybody
else you would get bonus presence and
eventually I stopped doing it after I
had like my nieces and nephews them
ended the winner our churches and softy
player asks oh no that's ask soft Tyler
asks what made you think this was a good
idea absolutely nothing I knew this was
going to be a bad idea because this is
far colder than any normal ice bath I
can't feel my toes or balls ah mark you
look really thirsty do not you do not
I'm serious do not mean I'm serious do
not you need do not assume not do not do
you simply thought you look really
thirsty take a sip [ __ ] you it's really
good
[Music]
Reptar skin doggie addmarker bak asks
how deep are you on the naughty list
well as you can see I'm about as deep as
you can go pretty much balls deep if you
know what I mean and fallen fools asks
why would you even bathe in eggnog
mark why I don't know I didn't prepare
for this
I'm a [ __ ] idiot okay I just do four
views oh my god what didn't I [ __ ]
get questions before I got the bath if
you were a rapper over your stake and B
and why this is not a Christmas related
question and it awfully obviously would
be mark a pimp daddy 29 [ __ ] will yo you
give me the Ziggy's up know what the
[ __ ] that means
Christmas what's the worst gift you gave
somebody I don't actually give bad gifts
I think very carefully about that's a
[ __ ] life I get everything
last-minute and then usually I just do
something technology related and hope
they don't mind I'm so bad that I just
buy things from Amazon and pay them to
give rabbit that's how bad it buying
gifts I am oh my toes are hurt at work
fishbowl asks does chica have a
Christmas sweater yeah she's got a lot
of Christmas outfits we put her in
ancient ones and we wanted to put her in
well but you didn't actually take the
lady look she doesn't like that Oh sir
to get really cool oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god
okay ah what the hell is a name said
travelling anywhere during the holidays
go to visit your family yes we're gonna
be doing uh a vacation back in 2000 and
I'm gonna be able to spend about two
weeks with my friends and family over
the holidays and they'll try to prefer
why we're doing a knishmas Fred asks if
you could choose what would be your
perfect Christmas day the perfect
Christmas day would be one where I can
actually sleep in because I almost
always get up at 8 a.m. go downstairs
spend time with my friends and family
spend all day cooking enjoy opening
presents and seeing everybody else get
their presents and just relax for one
day and that's what I'm looking for so
thank you for the question oh no please
put oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh
oh it's [ __ ] cold now I'm gonna go in
the shower
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh oh oh a powerful
powerful chief [ __ ] you [ __ ]
this water is warm he loves me as fast
as beautiful Oh God yeah so uh I'm gonna
be here for a while
hope you guys enjoyed the video thank
you so much for watching thank you for
all your questions
this was very stupid I don't know why we
did it even why did we do this yeah yeah
that was your idea get in the [ __ ]
back oh no no Tyler please please
okay so we're all done here thank you
everybody so much for watching and if
you're asking yourself yes it was
horrible right even yes it was the worst
thing yeah it was pretty bad
because the eggnog has different things
besides water in it such as solving
sugar and fats which if you know when
you put salt in ice
it makes it actually colder than
freezing temperature water so that was
extremely cold but we got to answer some
of you guys as Christmas related
questions so thank you everybody so much
for watching
now I'm gonna drain this demon bath but
I have to stick my oh that's good but
either way Thank You Tyler
Thank You Ethan and thank you guys so
much for joining us and as always we
will see you in the next video bye bye